credit card numbers birth dates phone
numbers names
addresses passport numbers what do they
all
have in common cloud dlp can protect
them all
how does it do it stay tuned to find out
[Music]
[Applause]
so by now you know that the
identification can be accomplished with
a few different techniques
each with their own benefits and
features
but you might wonder how does dlp know
what's what
how does it know when it spotted a phone
number for instance in the data
processes
and how sure is it when dlp inspects
data the results for any matches
include a certainty score that we call
the likelihood
the likelihood can be one of five scores
that range from
very unlikely to very likely
likelihood is important because it lets
you fine-tune the scope of your data
identification
and weed out potential false positives
by setting a confidence threshold
based on likelihood how is livelihood
determined
well for each of the 120 built-in info
types
this score is determined differently
depending on the corresponding input
type detector
that's the detection mechanism that
matches on a certain set of criteria
this criteria could include pattern
matching or checksum
it can even consider the surrounding
context that can be
identified in the data around the
potential match
time for an example take a look at this
string
what do you think we're looking at here
well it could be a job title followed by
an arbitrary identification number on
the other hand it could also be a
person's name
and a phone number when we run this
through a dop inspection job as expected
we get
two info type matches kitty walker is
identified
as the info type person name with a
likelihood score of
likely and the 10 digit number got
matched to phone number
with likelihood score of possible
now let's take a look at the same data
with some positive context mixed in
for us it's a lot more obvious what
we're looking at
and similarly cloud dlp considers the
context surrounding the data
and elected score jumps to very likely
for both
person name and phone number
dlp's use of context makes it especially
effective for conversational text
and transcripts once data is inspected
and classified by info type and
likelihood
dlp can then apply the identification
so let's talk about one of the most
basic forms of the identification
redaction what's redaction
when working with text redaction
completely removes the sensitive values
from your data without a trace
poof it leaves no clue as to what was
removed
let's see how the dlp api handles
redaction by looking at a request from a
node.js
app when we use a dlp api to inspect
content
we construct a request object that looks
like this
in the request we of course specify the
item that we want to scan
we also provide an inspection
configuration that configures the
scanning process
here we can limit the scope by providing
a likelihood threshold
or any particular info types that we
might want to limit our scan to
next there's a de-identification
configuration
this is where we specify that with each
match we want to de-identify it with
redaction
the response we get for this request
will have the transform data
in an overview that includes a summary
of the inspection and transformation for
each info type found for text
redaction is one of the most simplest
forms of de-identification
because it leaves no trace of what was
removed
the same concept can be applied to
images using
image redaction in this case dlp uses
optical character recognition to find
potential text in an image
and overlays an opaque bar over any
suspected sensitive values
let's take a look at another nodejs
request this time for this image
the request object is a bit different
this time
we once again provide an inspection
configuration where we can indicate
likelihood
and info types we have the option of
passing redaction configuration options
here
but by default you'll just place a black
bar
only on the text that it matches and
finally
we provide the image converted to a
string along the file type
the response here will be a new image
this time
with bars covering the redacted data
boom
our image has successfully been
de-identified thanks to image redaction
so whether you're working with text or
images redaction is the way to go when
you want to totally and completely
remove those sensitive values from your
data although the identification
reduction
is powerful i did mention that it's one
of the most simplest forms of
de-identification
next time we'll take a look at a more
complex technique
and talk about the identification using
crypto based tokenization
see you then
[Music]